so the cool thing about this Walmart is
it's open 24 hours and as you probably
know most blu-rays come out on Tuesdays
and so if you go there Monday night
after midnight you can actually request
a blu-ray or a DVD that's coming out on
Tuesday and they will give it to you
they'll actually just you know like go
on the back and yeah it's yours and
that's kind of I'm doing now it's Monday
it's after midnight I'm going to see
what comes out on Tuesday see if I can
check it out
so one thing you got to do is you got to
check the five-dollar DVD I like I call
it the five dollar DVD barrel I mean
it's a barrel two giant barrel filled
with more than likely not-so-great
movies I robots all right though and
every once in a while you get like you
know you get Howard the Duck which is
obviously you know that I should just
put that underneath something so no one
ever sees it but you know you get some
gems in there to find some some random
films that are actually fantastic that
are only five bucks but for the most
part I've become addicted to blu-ray so
I don't really care so much about these
piles anymore but they're still kind of
entertaining because where else can you
can you find you know Barbie the magic
of Pegasus it just
yeah anywhere else you know this was
just one of those movies that for some
reason I kind of appreciate it I don't
know why I just think I just watched it
at just the right time because I wanted
to watch a stupid silly movie and I
think Anna Faris is really cute so and
that was just a disappointment
unfortunately it was had so much
potential
this however that needs to be purchased
it's only 20 bucks - for three days
combo five script see when you a bowl
made in the name of the king it was
clear that everyone wanted a sequel to
it of course and you know he's one of
the few directors who's cool enough to
actually go and direct the sequel even
if I go straight to DVD and I mean that
just shows this how you know much of a
talent he is and how cool the guy he is
clearly you know we're gonna do we're
just gonna kind of go put that on top of
that so yeah this is awesome this is for
12 bucks 1196 photo dreams I yeah this
is like one of my favorite films
actually I love Philter dreams if you
haven't seen this you need to check it
out it's like one of those movies that
just gives you goosebumps it's just I
don't know I need to get that I'm not
the only one that feels kind of sorry
for Brandon Ralph I mean poor guy was in
Superman and things are looking good and
now now this is all we have poor guy so
much would get him a hug see I think
it's funny that in the Valentine's Day
section they have Blue Valentine a great
movie but if you watch this with your
date you will break up immediately and
it shouldn't be here great movie though
see this right here is why people love
Walmart the feature film packs so that
if you want to get for Steven Seagal
movies for $13 you can because clearly
that's a big seller you know or you can
want to watch platoon but settle for
Flyboys and Windtalkers because you know
clearly those are three movies of equal
quality now a lot of people have told me
to watch The Crow and I will definitely
get around to it because Alex Proyas
is a really good visual director but I
just want to point out that this film is
rated R for a great amount of strong
violence I find that very entertaining
Walmart's also the place where you can
find a film like Quantum of Solace which
was a big disappointment for 750 do a
quick little turnaround and save
yourself about 250 now this needs to be
talked about The Last Samurai great
movie
$10 on blu-ray over here we have Mortal
Kombat annihilation one of the worst
films I've ever seen in my life
$15 now and what world does that make
sense and this obviously makes me mad
last time I was here I asked if they had
the Bourne trilogy on blu-ray I was
there probably like three or four days
ago and they told me that they did not
have it I bet you they had in the back I
bet you they had it in the back and they
were just like who cares about this kid
I'm not going out there and getting it
lost 50 bucks I'm buying it somewhere
else now something tells me rihanna must
have saw Sin City I'm pretty sure she
saw Sin City you know I'm starting to
realize just about everything is cheaper
on Amazon honestly and I probably not
gonna buy too much brand-new blu-rays at
Walmart everything is cheaper online but
I have a great idea for a future video I
saw Dragonball Evolution for two dollars
and fifty cents at a used electronics
store and you know that's my least
favorite movie of all time and I think
I'm going to make a video just just
torturing that thing I'm just gonna I'm
going to set it on fire I'm gonna hit it
I'm gonna throw it out the window I'm
gonna smack it I'm gonna do all kinds of
things to it and it's gonna that sounded
wrong it's going to make me very happy
because as you know I hate that film I
think it could be a very entertaining
video so look forward to that next time
until next time guys thanks a lot for
watching and I will see you later if you
like this vlog you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck mine eyes